well some breaking news concerning the
vaccine
roll out now we brought you the news
earlier that 25 million
people have now had a first dose of the
vaccine well the government's vaccine
task force
has now notified uk the uk health
service
of a significant reduction in supply
from the manufacturers
in the week commencing the 29th
of march so just under two weeks time
the implications of that
meaning that new guidance is being
issued today to focus
on cohorts one to nine presumably the
second doses
of the vaccines for those it comes
as national booking has opened up to
everyone over
50. at the next post period we'll be
focusing on vaccinating those in cohorts
one to nine who are most vulnerable
as well as delivering to the agreed
schedule significantly
increased numbers of second doses which
will double from
the beginning of april so a letter from
the vaccine
task force has just been published let's
bring in our deputy political editor
sam coats who's had a look at it and sam
what does this say problems ahead for
the roll out of the vaccine
that's right sarah the letter which has
just been leaked to sky news uh
has uh his hair in my hand and it is
essentially
bad news bad news on two fronts first of
all
it says that there's a significant
constraint in supply of the vaccine
coming
from the week beginning march the 29th
uh
which is uh an ominous
sign and secondly the letter uh sets out
what the nhs is going to do
in order to deal uh with the
consequences of the constrained supply
and that's bad news for people who are
under 50 who haven't yet had the first
jab
because the guidance from the nhs
is that they're going to put on hold
effectively
people who haven't currently been
invited for
a vaccine inviting them to take
the jab and instead are going to
concentrate and restrict vaccinations
uh to those who are effectively uh
getting their second vaccine
uh their second job three months after
they got uh their first one so uh
if i just take you through some of the
key language uh
in the letter uh now the letter comes
from uh the
chief commercial uh officer uh and uh a
representative on the vaccine program
from nhs
england so it'll be interesting to see
quite how the duval administrations uh
respond to this in scotland and wales
but uh in northern ireland
but it says look uh the letter says from
the start of the program the nhs has
successfully had to adjust week to week
uh because of light fluctuations uh in
supply
however the government's vaccines task
force have now notified us that there
will be significant reductions in supply
available for manufacturers
in the week beginning march the 29th
meaning volumes of the first dates will
be significantly constrained
the they now currently predict that this
will continue for a full week period
as a result of reductions in national
inbound vaccine supply so
just pause there on the letter to make a
couple of points
first of all i interviewed the head of
the vaccine task force what three weeks
ago
and he was making clear he couldn't see
any circumstances in which there would
be a constraint in
supply he said the country has a lot and
predicted that the whole country could
have had both jabs
by august if not earlier
so he was very clear that he didn't
think that there was a
a likelihood of a constraint in supply
this now seems to be
uh the impact of uh of of that
secondly it's interesting that uh
they're talking about a limited
four-week period in which they
uh believe there to be a constraint and
supply quite why
that's the time frame that we have
identified whether it's because that's
what they're expecting
uh to be the decreased stocks from for
instance astrazeneca in the eu in case
of some
uh action to block some exports by the
eu which hasn't
yet been announced or the constraints
and supplies for some other reason
we don't yet know so the advice as a
result of that
reduction in supply is whilst
acknowledging that they've opened
national booking
today for everyone age 50 uh
and over and you can see in the top left
of your screen uh 48
percent of the country uh has been uh
vaccinated
uh they say that they're going to what
they say maximize
uptake in cohorts one to nine in other
words you can see in the top left of
your screen 1.75
million people have had the second
vaccine and i think now what they're
going to do is
close bookings to people who are under
50 they're not going to move down those
age cohorts as had been expected
in the timeframe that had been expected
but instead they're going to concentrate
on giving people
uh their second jabs and here is the key
sentence a key couple of sentences in
the letter they say inviting patients
outside of cohorts one to nine will
only be permissible in exceptional
circumstances those aged
49 or younger should not be offered
vaccination
unless they are eligible via a higher
cohort because for instance
they're clinically vulnerable an unpaid
carer or a frontline health
and care worker and they say to ensure
prioritization compliance and to
minimize uh
the waste that you might experience uh
they should
that clinicians should prioritize all
stock with a limited uh
shelf life and work with local
organizations in order to identify
uh who should be the people receiving uh
the um
receiving the doses fair as fairly as
possible
and they say that there will be more
information sent out by the nhs
in england shortly in order to go
through this now
um until now the government has ridden
off the back of extremely successful
uh rollout of the vaccine program
anything that indicates a reduction in
supply will be
uncomfortable for them particularly
people who had been expecting their jabs
for instance people in their early 40s
who thought that they might get jabs in
for instance the first couple of weeks
of april
will now be likely disappointed by the
slade
rollout there is of course a three-month
lag between people getting their first
and their second
jabs longer than there is uh longer than
the lag in
some other countries but the decision of
the nhs
will be to uh to stick with that
and to uh ensure that people um who need
their second jabs are prioritized rather
than
uh moving further down uh the age uh
cohort
uh we've heard a lot today about the
vaccine roll out not only was the
government
uh not that long ago not many hours ago
celebrating the fact that they were
opening up the vaccine
roll out to those age 50 and over
but also you were hearing this morning
some of the drama around the
decision to prioritize the entire
vaccine program and who should get the
political spoils
as it were for a successful rollout
operation when dominic cummings the
former top aide to boris johnson
appeared
before the select committee and it's a
mark of just how successful it has been
that different bits of government have
been arguing about
you should get the credit for the
vaccine rollout uh and this will be
a blip now it's not yet clear how much
of a blip
uh it will end up amounting to there are
some uh
uh forecasters who say that a small dip
or even a moderate size
dip in supply uh over the next four
weeks or so won't dramatically alter
uh the trajectory for most people
getting uh
uh at least their first jab by june uh
and potentially even both jabs
uh by uh august or september
um but i think that just the news and
the formal announcement being rolled out
to clinicians all over the
uh country that um that there has been
in the words of uh the medical director
for primary care
and the chief commercial officer for nhs
england
uh significantly constrained supply in
the coming weeks
ahead will be unwelcome news for many